On the 11th of December 1936, a man spoke
on the BBC.
Millions of listeners held their breath as
he announced his resolve to go forward with
a decision which was, and remains, unique
in British history: his abdication to the
throne.
That man was Edward VIII.
The reason behind his abdication was his love
for a woman that the British Court and the
establishment would have never accepted as
a Queen: the American, twice divorced, Wallis
Simpson.
In today’s Biographics we are going to present
their story.
One of frustration, unhappy marriages and
fraught relationships.
The story of how a man and a woman renounced
to the British Crown, apparently for love,
and of how they were tempted to reclaim the
throne by the machinations of their supposed
enemy, the Third Reich.
Edward
Edward was born on the 23rd of June 1894 in
Richmond, Surrey.
He was the eldest child of the future King
George V, the grandchild to King Edward VII,
and a great-grandchild to Queen Victoria,
who was still alive at the time of his birth.
He was always known in his family as David,
the last of his many middle names.
From this youth, Edward was set on a naval
career.
However, the quick ascension to the throne
of his father George V in 1910 meant that
Edward was immediately appointed Prince of
Wales on his 16th birthday.
Edward had to quit his naval studies and enrolled
at Oxford.
It’s generally agreed that Edward was intellectually
underwhelming, or maybe just not that interested
in studying.
Besides a good performance with his polo team
at Oxford, he had little academic achievement
and left university after eight terms with
no degree.
At the outbreak of WWI Edward joined the Grenadier
Guards.
The young Prince was keen to see action on
the Western front, like his rival, counterpart
and relative, the German Crown Prince Wilhelm.
However, the British Government forbade this,
for the risk of losing the heir to the throne.
After the war, in January 1919, Edward’s
youngest brother, the Prince John, died aged
13.
After a long struggle with epilepsy, the young
prince had succumbed to a seizure.
On this occasion Edward referred to John’s
death as
“little more than a regrettable nuisance.”
His contacts with John were so limited due
to his illness, that he remembered him as
“more of an animal than anything else”
Edward had to write a letter to his mother,
apologising for being such a
“cold-hearted and unsympathetic swine”
Throughout the 1920s, Edward undertook extensive
foreign tours particularly in the British
Empire, representing his father.
Edward also took to visiting areas of high
unemployment and deprivation in Britain, during
the economic depression of the early 1930s.
These occasions made his figure familiar and
popular with the press and the public.
His image at this stage was that of a dashing
dandy: good-looking, well dressed, skilled
at playing polo and flying airplanes.
He had earned a pilot’s licence in 1918
and was the first British monarch to ever
fly an aircraft.
In the 1920s Edward also dedicated time to
another passion.
He had a string of affairs with several married
women, which cemented his status as the World’s
most desirable bachelor.
At the same time, his affairs seemed to keep
him from fulfilling one of his duties as Prince
of Wales: finding a suitable match.
In late 1930, Edward had started a relationship
with Thelma, Viscountess Furness, also married
at the time.
It was Thelma who, probably in January 1931
introduced her to a beautiful, intelligent
and witty American friend, Wallis Simpson.
Wallis[TA1]
Wallis Simpson was born Bessie-Wallis Warfield
on the 19th of June, 1896, in Blue Ridge Summit,
Pennsylvania.
This was a SPA town where her father Teackle
Wallis was seeking treatment for tuberculosis,
which unfortunately claimed his life when
Bessie was only a few months old.
Alice, Bessie’s mother, was an impoverished
widow, but fortunately she was taken in by
Solomon, her late husband’s rich brother,
living in Baltimore.
Solomon also paid for Bessie-Wallis’ education
in an exclusive all-girl private school.
As a teenager in Baltimore, Wallis dropped
the ‘Bessie’ and was subject to many girlhood
passions.
She fell madly in love with two teachers and
several girlfriends and sent them letters
describing them as “beautiful little partridges”.
There is no proof that she may have had homosexual
relationships, though.
After graduating, Wallis dated many handsome
men, despite not being well-off nor especially
good looking by the standards of that time.
In 1916, Wallis married an airman called Win
Spencer.
The marriage was not a happy one.
When Win tried to kiss her on their wedding
night, Wallis recoiled.
Later she asserted that the marriage was never
consummated.
The marriage was doomed to failure.
Win was transferred to China, where their
relationship eventually broke down, because
of Win’s alcoholism and sadism.
Wallis left the household and went to live
with her friend Katherine and her husband,
Herman Rogers.
Herman was not just a friend, Wallis considered
him to be the true love of her life.
Although according to her biographer Andrew
Morton, also this relationship never evolved
into a sexual one.
Later, she met a South American man, Felipe
Espil, who also undoubtedly became the true
love of Wallis’s life, though she definitely
never had sex with him either.
Wallis then moved to England where she married
Anglo-American businessman Ernest Simpson.
Ernest may not have shared Win’ alcoholism
nor sadism, but also this second marriage
was a platonic relationship.
Again, this is Wallis’ own version as reported
by Morton.
In London, Wallis became friends with Thelma
Viscountess Furness, who introduced her to
Edward.
From then on Wallis became a regular presence
of the royal social scene and she started
to receive letters signed simply ‘PW’
– Prince of Wales.
Wallis and Edward[TA2]
When the affair between Thelma and the Prince
of Wales came to an end, Wallis took her friend’s
place.
Very early in the relationship, Wallis became
indispensable to his household.
She organised his dinner parties and went
on exotic foreign holidays with him.
Royal courtiers were not openly hostile at
this stage, yet they were wary of Wallis’
hold on the Prince.
Again, evidence suggests that their relationship
was not of a physical nature, and there are
questions about the true nature of their attraction.
Wallis may have been attracted only by the
proximity to power, while Edward may have
seen in Wallis, a twice divorcee, a way out
from his future duties as a King.
But Edward soon had to face reality: on the
29th of January 1936 George VI died after
a prolonged illness.
It was time for his Accession to the throne.
The new King did not have any intention to
interrupt his love story with Wallis and the
two continued to be seen together in official
occasions, such as the Proclamation of his
own Accession.
At this stage their affair was not widely
known to the public, as British establishment
did their best to hush up the whole story.
But members of the high society had started
spreading stories which made their way to
the US and other countries.
Readers abroad started to collect news clippings
from gossip columns and post them to relatives
in the UK.
In other cases, foreign magazines carrying
the news were sold in London.
An article from the Milwaukee Journal, dated
30th of October 1936 tells how American newspapers
were mysteriously removed from newsstands
in central London.
Sometimes, just a selection of pages was ripped
out.
After a while, the whole world seemed to be
in on the story – except for the British
press who feigned ignorance or just chose
to ignore the affair.
When Wallis finally divorced her husband,
a modern-day journalist would have made a
field day out of it: this meant that Wallis
and Edward were one step closer to marrying.
And yet it was covered by a single article,
at the bottom of page 10 in The Guardian.
The story of the affair between the King and
a twice-divorcée American finally exploded
in December 1936 when Bishop Blunt of Bradford
denounced the couple from his pulpit.
With the cat out of the bag, and with Wallis’
divorce out of the way, a word started to
make the rounds amongst the British Cabinet
of Ministers: abdication.
As King of Great Britain and Northern Ireland,
Edward was also head of the Church of England.
At that time the Church did not allow for
divorcees to re-marry, unless their former
spouse was already dead.
So, could the head of the Anglican faith violate
one of the tenets of his own Church?
For this reason, the Cabinet feared that the
British people would never accept Wallis as
Queen.
Edward had to choose: either Wallis, or the
Crown.
But actually, at the beginning he tried to
negotiate with the Cabinet.
He had already proposed the idea of a morganatic
marriage to Prime Minister Baldwin, in November
1936.
A morganatic marriage would leave Edward on
the throne, assign to Wallis a lesser title
instead of queen, and would have revoked rights
of succession to any offspring.
When Baldwin rejected the proposal, Edward
had only one option left.
Abdication[TA3]
On the 10th of December 1936, King Edward
VIII submitted his abdication to the Government,
which was endorsed by the Parliament on the
next day.
He had become the only British monarch ever
to resign voluntarily.
His brother Albert, Duke of York, would rise
to the throne as King George VI.
On the 11th of December, the now former Edward
VIII announced his decision to the nation
on the radio:
“A few hours ago I discharged my last duty
as King and Emperor, and now that I have been
succeeded by my brother, the Duke of York,
my first words must be to declare my allegiance
to him.
This I do with all my heart.
You all know the reasons which have impelled
me to renounce the throne.
But I want you to understand that in making
up my mind I did not forget the country or
the empire, which, as Prince of Wales and
lately as King, I have for twenty-five years
tried to serve.
But you must believe me when I tell you that
I have found it impossible to carry the heavy
burden of responsibility and to discharge
my duties as King as I would wish to do without
the help and support of the woman I love.
And I want you to know that the decision I
have made has been mine and mine alone.
This was a thing I had to judge entirely for
myself.
The other person most nearly concerned has
tried up to the last to persuade me to take
a different course.”
This part was true, although at the time few
believed Edward’s words.
Wallis was horrified at the idea that Edward
would abdicate for her, and tried to talk
him out of it.
Theirs had only been an affair, not real love.
Wallis was still in love with Felipe and with
Herman.
But once the abdication was announced, she
felt obliged to go through with the charade
and marry Edward, now styled the Duke of Windsor.
Biographer Andrew Morton reveals that on the
day before the wedding, she begged Herman,
her one true love, to get her pregnant.
This would not have been possible, as a previous
surgical operation had left Wallis incapable
of conceiving.
In any case, Herman refused her proposal.
Edward and Wallis married on the 3rd of June
1937 at the Château de Cande, near Tours,
in France.
A Guardian article from the time reports that
Herman Rogers was present and very active
at the ceremony.
He played host to the groom, walked Wallis
to the altar and even delivered an address
to the press on behalf of Edward, asking for
the couples’ privacy to be respected.
Based on what we know today about Wallis and
Herman, the whole wedding must have felt incredibly
awkward for the two souls.
In any case, the marriage was sealed, and
the newlyweds left for a three month honeymoon
in Austria.
Yet again, based on Morton’s accounts, also
Wallis’ third marriage remained unconsummated.
The Windsors and Nazi Germany
For the following two years, Wallis and Edward,
or the Windsors, lived mainly in France.
The relationships between them and the Royal
Family were severely strained.
Edward was furious at George VI for refusing
to style Wallis as ‘Her Royal Highness’.
On the other hand, George forbade his brother
to return to Britain, lest he rescind his
generous allowance.
The relationship with the Court, and with
the Cabinet, worsened when the Windsors visited
Germany in October 1937.
The official reason for the visit was for
Edward to learn more about the regime’s
employment and housing policies.
In truth, Edward was craving for a princely
treatment – especially for Wallis – and
knew that the German leadership were all too
keen to roll out the red carpet.
In addition to that, he saw himself as a mediator
between Britain and Germany
During their visit the Windsors met with Goering,
Foreign Minister von Ribbentrop, Goebbels,
Himmler, Rudolph Hess.
They even spent two hours with the Fuhrer
and the Duke was photographed delivering a
Nazi salute.
The British Government saw this as an embarrassment.
Two years later, after the declaration of
war on Germany, Edward was appointed liaison
officer to the French Army.
When the Germans finally invaded in May 1940,
the Windsors escaped to southern France, then
on to neutral Spain and finally in Portugal
in July.
New Prime Minister, Winston Churchill, was
keen to get the Windsors back to Britain as
soon as possible.
But the Duke delayed proceedings as he wanted
to negotiate a post befitting to his rank
and “simple courtesies” for Wallis.
In other words: recognition of their royal
status.
Meanwhile, the Germans were conspiring to
get hold of the Windsors.
In their plan, should the invasion of Britain
succeeded, Edward would have made a good collaborationist
King.
Their theory was confirmed by the intelligence
reports flying in from Madrid and Lisbon,
according to which
“Windsor spoke strongly against Churchill
and against this war,”
and that the Duke was
“convinced that had he remained on the throne,
war would have been avoided and describes
himself as a firm supporter of peaceful compromise
with Germany”
The telegram from Lisbon continued with a
sinister note:
“The Duke believes with certainty that continued
heavy bombing will make England ready for
peace.”
A certain show about the British Royal Family
builds on this idea, that Edward may have
inspired the carpet bombing of civilian targets
in Britain.
This is not verified and surely the Luftwaffe
did not need this passing comment to inspire
their strategic plans.
What we can say with more certainty though
is that Edward was potentially pro-Nazi, still
believed in the 1930s politics of appeasement
and was a defeatist, to say the least.
Churchill was aware of the danger of the Duke’s
declarations and so issued orders to keep
an eye on him, lest he speak against the Allied
war effort to the press.
He even sent him a direct warning, ordering
him not to mention
“any view about the war, or about the Germans,
or about Hitlerism, which is different from
that adopted by the British nation and Parliament.”
But the Duke’s delaying tactics continued.
Churchill’s ultimate solution was to get
the Duke as far away from Europe as possible
by appointing him Governor of The Bahamas.
But Edward refused, claiming the Bahamas to
be a “third-class British colony” and
considered returning to Spain as Franco’s
guest instead.
Von Ribbentrop took advantage of the stalling
situation and sent an explicit offer to the
Windsors:
“Germany is determined to force England
to peace by every means of power and upon
this happening would be prepared to accommodate
any desire expressed by the Duke, especially
with a view to the assumption of the English
throne by the Duke and Duchess.”
The offer did not solicit an immediate agreement,
but neither a flat-out rejection.
A German agent reported that the Duchess appeared
to be considering this proposal very thoughtfully.
But this was not enough for Berlin.
The Germans needed to take the Windsors back
to Madrid, to better control them, and so
they launched a secret operation, codenamed
‘Willi’ to ensure that the Duke bent to
their will.
The head of Nazi counterintelligence, Walter
Schellenberg travelled to Lisbon to oversee
the simple plan.
It involved a threatening message relayed
by Miguel Primo de Rivera, a Spanish nationalist
very close to Franco.
De Rivera informed the Windsors that they
had uncovered a British plot to murder them
and urged them to seek Spain’s protection.
Eventually, Plan Willi failed.
Winston Churchill threatened the Duke with
a Court Martial if he refused to accept the
post in the Bahamas.
Edward was after all a Major-General of the
Army, and subject to military justice.
The Windsors eventually left for the Bahamas
on August 1, 1940.
The Duke may have still been wary of the warnings
from De Rivera, as he demanded a Scotland
Yard detective for personal protection.
Edward had been physically removed from the
war in Europe, but he still managed to score
more embarrassing situations.
In late 1940, for example, when interviewed
by an American magazine, he said:
“There will be no revolution in Germany
and it would be a tragic thing for the world
if Hitler were to be overthrown.
Hitler is the right and logical leader of
the German people… Hitler is a very great
man.”
As a Governor of the Bahamas, Edward disliked
the job, but he did some good work there.
The Duke launched initiatives to raise wages
for Bahamians and promoted plans to relieve
poverty.
But true to character, he could not help yet
another faux pas.
As he addressed these social problems, he
blamed them on
“men of Central European Jewish descent,
who had secured jobs as a pretext for obtaining
a deferment of draft.”
Life after the War[TA4]
Full reports on the whole relationship between
the Windsors and Nazi Germany were collected
after the War in the so-called Windsor File.
Most of it, however, remains classified, and
for the moment we will not know the full extent
of the Duke’s sympathy or even collaboration
with the regime.
What we have, are his public declarations
and interviews.
In the 1950s he blamed WWII on
“anti-appeasement politicians in Britain,
Roosevelt and the Jews”
In 1966 he told an American newspaper the
believed the UK should not have intervened.
“I thought the rest of us could be fence
sitters while the Nazis and the Reds slogged
it out,”
And privately, he expressed the view that
“I never thought Hitler was such a bad chap,”
After the war the Windsors lived between the
US and France.
On the outside, it appeared as if Wallis and
the former king lived a happy life of leisure,
thanks to the allowance still granted to them.
But the reality was not as it seemed, as Andrew
Morton has uncovered by reviewing Wallis’
letters.
Edward was always besotted, completely infatuated
with her.
Wallis always treated him with deference and
respect, at least in public.
She always referred to him as ‘the Duke’
and called him ‘Sir’ in public.
But in private, things were very different.
She spent her days being unpleasant to all
those around her, and treated with harsh coldness
especially her husband, to whom she denied
any intimate contact.
He would often say to her, ‘Am I going to
go to bed in tears again tonight?’
According to Morton, all they shared in later
life was
“a mutual interest in golf, fascism and
casual racism”
Wallis never forgot her first true loves,
for Felipe, but especially for Herman.
Many of the letters uncovered by Morton, in
fact are addressed to him.
When Herman and Felipe died, Wallis was devastated,
and she retreated from the world paying little
to no attention to her husband.
Edward paid only short visits to Britain after
the War, mainly to attend funerals of family
members.
His relationship with the Royal Family remained
strained and distant.
His health deteriorated and in the early 1970s
Edward was diagnosed with throat cancer.
During his dying moments, on the 28th of May
1972, the former King was being comforted
by a nurse.
With his last breath he whispered
‘Wallis, Wallis and Wallis,’
But Wallis was not there.
Edward died in the arms of a stranger, rather
than the woman for whom he had abdicated.
After the Duke’s death, Wallis settled in
Paris.
Once a known socialite, described as one of
the best dressed women in the world, Wallis
retreated from the world and stopped entertaining.
She died of coronary heart disease on the
24th of April 1986.
Without any heirs nor relatives, she left
her estate to the Pasteur research institute.
What if … ?
And so ends one of the saddest personal stories
of the XXth Century.
As Wallis and Edward’s lives have been told
on film many times I will not ask you to suggest
a cast for yet another biopic.
But rather to consider this: considering what
we know about Edward’s pro-appeasement and
potentially pro-Nazi stance, what would have
happened if he had not abdicated?
Could an extended reign of Edward VIII have
changed the course of history?
How would have WWII played out in such a scenario?
Please post your alternative histories in
the comments …. And as usual, thank you
for watching.